نعم لا شك ان قليل حصلت هنالك هزه وانا
اثناء المقابله مما اضطرني الى المغادره
المنزل مباشره وكذلك ايضا حصول الشقوق في
داخل المبنى الذي اخطن به فيه حاليا هنالك
عده شقوق في اعمده التي تحمل البناء كذلك
ايضا مخاطر التي من الممكن ان تحصل نتيجه
لهذا لهذه التساقطات لذلك لجات الى الخروج
خارج يعني خارج المنزل بعيد عن المنزل الى
منطقه فارغه ربما المبدا الخلفي تشاهده
عباره عن مبنى طابقين فقط لا غير خشيه ان
يكون هنالك انهيارات نظرا لان هذه هنالك
تحضيرات ايضا ربما قد تكون هنالك ايضا
ارتداديه اخرى وبالتالي نتحدث عن استمرار
تلك الهزات لساعات وربما قد تكون متقدمه
ولا يمكن التكهل بما هي تلك الهزات وحجم
تلك الهزات وحجر المباني التي تتضررت
نتيجه لتلك الهزات السابقه وانها ربما قد
لا تقوى على على
ان تكون
حصينه لتلك الارت التي ستخدم بعد قليل
لذلك يعني
ربما من شاهدتكم انصح كل من هو متواجد
داخل المباني السكنيه ان يلجا الى الساحات
الفارغه بعيدا الابنيه والمباني السكنيه
ذات الطوابق العاليه نتيجه نظرا لان ربما
قد تنهرت تلك الابنيه وبالتالي لاقي ربما
قد يكون هنا يفارق الحياه نتيجه تلك
الهزات الارتداديه التي من المحتمل ان
تكون هنالك هزات اخرى قبل قليل اتابع من
عبر شاشتكم انه لا توجد احصائيات رسميه
حتى هذه اللحظه لعدد تلك الهافات وبالتالي
نتحدث عن الاستمرار من تلك الهزهات نظرا
لعدم وجود احصائيه رسميه واستمرار تلك
الهزات يعني اثناء المقابله نشاهد ونسمع
وخاصه في الطوابق العليا انا كنت قبل قليل
في الطابق الخامس لاحظت ذلك بشكل واضح حجم
الهزه ايضا الخزانات التي تعلو المبنى
ايضا تساقط بعض هذه الخزانات قبل قليل
لذلك اعتقد من الواجب هؤلاء المتواجدين او
في مناطق التي تشهد هذه الزلازل ان يخرج
الى الشوارع يبتعد عن تلك المنازل
ارواحهم نظرا لقد
هذا الحجم الهائل من الدمار الذي لحق بعدد
من المباني حسب الصور الموجوده واللقطات
الموجوده في اكثر من منطقه